bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france quelle solution aujourd'hui selon
vous pour faire face à cette situation à
lesbos la solution n'a des chances que
de passer que par le rock est en fait le
problème c'est que les boss est
totalement bloqué depuis cinq ans par un
nombre de migrants qui est énorme par
rapport à sa population que avant même
le virus fait tout de même plusieurs
années qui a plus aucun touriste à
lesbos alors quitté la ressource quand
même importante le résultat est temps
que les migrants qui s'y trouvent ont
l'impression d'être bloqué à vie et sens
de plus en plus à la foire angoissé et
furieuse qui explique certaines
réactions et que la population elle-même
est tout aussi angoissé et furieuse
parce que quand il est question de
reconstruire un camp les ans se disent
ah on va encore nous bloquer et les
autres se disent ah on va encore nous
les laissez donc les choses ou assez mal
c'est moins que l'on puisse dire là gaz
qui en appelle à l'union européenne
l'europe est trop lente selon vous à
réagir en général dans tootsie réaction
l'europe est lent parce qu'ils font que
tous les états se mettent d'accord entre
eux et de toute façon je veux dire pour
l'instant voyez on parle de 400 enfants
sur trets presque treize mille personnes
donc c'est merveilleux d'avoir 7 août
une réunion pour arriver à 400 enfants
et à ce que certains pays dits
généreusement je vais en prendre 40
donc c'est évident que c'est pas comme
ça que les questions peuvent se résoudre
mais alors comment comment faire
justement pour que les états membres
prennent peut-être leur part de
responsabilité dans cette question la
politique migratoire qui touche
l'ensemble de l'europe la tendance des
états membres sept ans est laissé le
poids sur les états méditerranéens en se
disant chic pour nous le problème est
plus lointain et puis en même temps
l'europe souffre finalement de n'avoir
pas défini vraiment une politique
migratoire c'est à dire veux ton ou non
des migrants ainsi c'est oui il faut
prendre une position ferme et tirer des
conséquences concrètes et si c'est non
aussi
or selon les états selon les moments
selon les circonstances
en fait jamais il n'ya eu vraiment
d'accord claire entre les vingt-sept là
dessus comment est ce que vous vous
juger la réaction immédiate du
gouvernement grec et notamment la
construction de ce nouveau camp à lesbos
cl je dirais que c'est là c'est la
conséquence de ce qui s'est passé juste
avant c'est à dire que c'est treize
mille migrants
finalement le gouvernement grec n'avait
guère envie de les transférer sur le
continent ne savais pas vraiment où les
maîtres sur le continent où il ya déjà
près de 100 mille migrants qui sont
hébergées de diverses manières avec une
contribution financière de la commission
européenne et des nations unies
et quand même temps peut-être
hypocritement mais l'europe elle-même se
dit que tant que ces migrants sont
bloqués dans les îles
en fait il ya peu de risque de les voir
arriver en europe
ils peuvent pas venir à l'ananas
jusqu'au pire est donc alors considéré
qu'une fois qu'ils sont sur le
territoire grec
il ya toujours la possibilité que
clandestinement en essayant de
s'infiltrer sur des bateaux en essayant
de passer des frontières et c'est un
beau jour on les voit arriver le
gouvernement grec doit composer aussi
avec la population et les habitants de
lesbos on a vu ces derniers jours
ces images d'habitants qui empêchaient
le passage de l'aide humanitaire pour
venir en aide aux migrants sans abris
aujourd'hui ah oui les habitants de
lesbos
bon il ya sept huit ans était avait été
félicité quasiment pour avoir très bien
gentiment accueilli les premiers
arrivants il cédera cochon et à mesure
des années ça c'est tendu que là ils
sont dans un état d'exaspération total à
la fois parce qu'effectivement ils
voient bien que nombre des migrants
grandi que finalement à cause d'eux
c'est bien dommage mais qu'à cause de
effectivement il ya plus de tourisme
donc ils ont beaucoup perdu campus
maintenant ces migrants ne sont plus
dans leur camp ou dans les ruines de
leur camp dans une extrémité de l'île
ils sont tous on les voit sur le
reportage ils sont tous finalement à
proximité de la capitale et du port
puisque leur leurs idées à eux c'est de
rejoindre la grèce continentale et
l'europe et donc en fait je veux dire
que là maintenant les gens l'ont les
sous le nez se disent que tous ces gens
là sans ressources vont sûrement se
mettre à jouer chaparder et c'est que
partout et qu'en plus on sait que parmi
les migrants avaient été repérés au
moins une quarantaine de personnes
atteints du coran la virus que toutes
les structures et tous les
renseignements administratifs les
ordinateurs etc grand brûlé et que donc
maintenant on sait que ces gens sont
contagieux et que et ben il se balade à
travers le pays et la capitale
merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage est
la valeur je rappelle que vous êtes
maître de conférences à l'institut
national des langues et civilisations
orientales